by the way so zilinski right now he
keeps calling for the no-fly zone
calling for jets he's calling for things
that you go hey man we can't do any of
this and he still just won't stop and
we support ukraine they should be able
to determine their own future or a
sovereign country and i think the
invasion is monstrous but i also believe
that like
you can't keep asking for a world war
three
you got to take a deal here buddy take a
deal of course you're not gonna like to
deal
but that's okay take a deal
and by the way i want you to get up
something right now because everybody's
like oh what do we do what do we do
i want you to have a word document right
now because i believe in the power of
the sternly worded letter i've always
believed that
think of when you were coming home you
know when a teacher tucked a letter in
your
pocket or your backpack that had to go
to your mother how terrified were you on
the bus
you were terrified and then you got home
maybe you were a latchkey kid and you
got to uh it's like going home with the
report card when there is a note that
you know your mother has to read from
the teacher and you can't even open it
you don't know what it really says and
sometimes you know what it says because
you watch the teacher write it and
you're like if i don't give it to my
mother i'm more than [ __ ] because the
teacher's gonna call cause the teacher
will tell you i'm calling to make sure
she read it dear vladimir putin okay
right now
cause enough's enough dear vladimir
putin
hey buddy
now what hey buddy does is right off the
bat he's wondering
is this are they is am i really his
buddy because when someone says hey
buddy it's kind of aggressive do you
know what i mean sure like your brother
says it nice he was a hey buddy but a
lot of people don't
uh hey buddy it's kind of like it's kind
of like a kind of an aggro move right so
you go hey buddy so right off the bat
right off the bat he's on the defensive
hey buddy next line okay
the war in ukraine you don't do that ben
you indent oh don't you know how to ride
well we already did deer so then we did
we do another indent i guess yeah well
because hey buddy's its own thing okay
okay
hey buddy
the war in ukraine
is
ridiculous
okay
this is not your best moment
in fact
it's literally one of your worst
it's not so much the bombing
or the shelling ben can you fix it sorry
it's not so much the bombing
or the shelling
of civilian of heavily civilian areas
if anyone understands that we do lol
because you wanna you wanna
you wanna also like build rapport
if anyone understands that we do lol
the reality is
that this is now [ __ ]
with everybody's money
and we know that was never your goal
but
that is what is happening
so
please cut it out
before we're all broke
and no one has enough money to kill
signed
barry weiss
signing barry weiss
read it back
dear vladimir putin
hey buddy
the war in ukraine is ridiculous this is
not your best moment in fact it's
literally one of your worst
it's not so much the bombing or the
shelling of heavily civilian areas if
anyone understands that we do lol
the reality is
that this is now [ __ ] with
everybody's money and we know that was
never your goal but that is what is
happening
so please cut it out before we are all
broke and no one has enough money to
kill
signed barry wise
you're telling me that has no effect i
doubt it
you're telling me that has no effect if
it goes over there and he realizes what
he's doing he's [ __ ] with everybody's
money we're all trying to build death
machines here
we're all trying to do it
we're all trying to run ponzi schemes in
the financial sector we're all trying to
build uh sick people for insulin money
we're all trying to [ __ ] over the poor
and and we're all trying to do this and
this guy's getting in the way now
because it's [ __ ] our money up with
the gas price is high how are we going
to drive all the kids to the private
prisons
you know how much it costs now to drive
a group of kids to a private prison
you know the cost of everything's gonna
go up not just gas plastics
metals the restraints that we put those
kids in ain't cheap
the materials to make the restraints
that we put our children in when we ship
them to a private prison
are not free
so this is [ __ ] everybody's money up
when we
fly some mission
to go bomb someone is that gas on the
house no
okay
when the police
are doing ride-alongs in different
neighborhoods looking for people to kill
they have to have gas as well
do you understand that
are you not with that or is something
wrong with you
okay
when a realtor drives a young couple
around
so she can trick them into buying a
house they can't afford and they take
out a mortgage that they can't pay back
and they spend the next 10 or 20 years
of their life
mired in hopeless depression and
addictions to just drag themselves out
of bed to go to the jobs they hate to
spend the money to pay that mortgage
while their children are literally
masturbating on only fans for money
who puts the gas in the car to get that
going
so what i'd like you to do
mr vladimir putin is realize
how hard it is for everybody
to participate in the society that we've
set up here
with a high price of fuel